people are gonna have to start paying
their fair share in taxes their fair
share are you paying your fair share
what would that be
you'll be specific on the tax rate you
know you look at our tax rates back in
the 60s when 60 Minutes the darling of
the progressive movement didn't appear
to have a specific rate in mind but then
she said sometimes you see tax rates as
high as 60 or 70% suddenly that became
the progressive plan I can support folks
at the top paying their fair share and
70% 80% we've had it as high as 90% 90%
was the top tax rate when I was a kid
and now Democrats say if we just raise
taxes on the wealthy government we'll
have plenty of money to pay for all
their wonderful programs but it's a myth
what progressives don't say is that no
one actually paid anywhere close to
those rates no one no one economic
historian Phil Magnus says it's not
surprising that progressives don't know
that 90% tax rates didn't bring in lots
of money you know who has the time and
the interest to sit around and dig
through that line-by-line yes me I'm
apparently the guy he's researched old
tax codes for over a decade you must be
a really boring guy i I can't be
during World War two America's 90% tax
bracket didn't bring in that much more
money because rich people found
loopholes and then because the high
rates discouraged work
President Kennedy backed a bill that
lowered the top rate to 70 percent the
billions of dollars this bill were
placed in the hands of the consumer and
our businessman will have both immediate
and permanent benefits to our economy
but it turned out that the 70% rate
wasn't very real either no one paid 70%
little 90% what did they pay a
millionaire on average would pay 41%
because when taxes are high rich people
find loopholes there's all these
deductions and exemptions and carve-outs
that are intentionally baked into the
tax code newspapers ran ads crews for
free $2,499 value and basically take a
vacation around the Caribbean but while
you're onboard the ship you attend say
an investing seminar or a real estate
seminar and then right off the trip the
whole trip the whole trip deductions
became so complex that rich people
instead of inventing say precursor to
the iPhone hired accountants to study
the tax code who can afford the best
accountants it's always the wealthy
today the top tax rate is 37 percent the
top rate started dropping again after
Ronald Reagan said 70 percent was
outrageous our tax system could only be
described as unamerican and the
Democrats actually agree with them
bragging goes to the table says let's
make a deal we can cut the rates down to
something closer and approximation to
what we have today and in exchange we'll
consolidate the tax code vacation
deductions and other exemptions were
killed leading to a slightly simpler tax
code and surprise the lower rates
brought in just as much money
turns out the tax revenue is a
percentage of the economy stays about
the same no matter what the top tax rate
is when rates are high rich people
sometimes worked less it's just
economics people don't work to pay taxes
economists art Laffer told President
Reagan rich
people will evade high taxes they'll
change where they earn their income
they'll change how they are their income
they'll change how much they earn when
they receive the income they'll change
all of those things to minimize taxes
they will leave the United States and
this not yet president pointed out that
if taxes go up rich people may move away
you haven't left I haven't left yet are
you going to leave big story if I leave
I guess if I leave New York that's a big
story look the rich people are going to
leave and other people are gonna leave
you're gonna end up with lots of people
that don't produce and then that's the
spiral that's the end and that's what's
happened and there's some European
example so France attempted a massive
tax on its wealthiest earners and what
they found is the businesspeople left
and a mass exodus from the kind of the
country but progressives are selective
when they look at history under
Republican president administration
Dwight Eisenhower we had 90 percent
marginal tax rate the government will
collect more and do good things well
that's the claim but you're asking for
an economic disaster though I ask the
question do we leave it in the private
sector where the market decides or do we
subject it to corrupt politicians I say
let the market decide of course when the
market decides some people get really
rich and then progressives say the rich
get richer and the poor get poorer but
that's not true the poor don't get poor
that's another economic myth we'll cover
that in an upcoming video